bien papa dennis qui est là et je le
vois hocher la tête qu'on vous dit
oui je suis pour la peine de mort votre
fils enis a été enlevée et violée par
francis evrard un délinquant succe
sexuel multirécidiviste
le 15 août 2007 enis joue devant chez
lui à roubaix est enlevée par francis
evrard mustapha vous prévenez la police
vous apercevez de la disparition de
votre fils une alerte enlèvement est
déclenché wii est déclenché et nice est
retrouvé quelques heures plus tard dans
un box avec son ravisseur dit j'ai reçu
une éducation qui fait que je n'aurais
pas fait de mal à un insecte avant 2007
j'étais contre la peine de mort j'aurais
aimé ne jamais à avoir changé d'avis
aujourd'hui vous avez changé de toute
affaire il est heureusement madame kelly
d'ailleurs pour ça moi j'ai eu une
éducation de mes parents qui m'ont
toujours appris défendre les faibles a
pas faire de mal même à un insecte mais
en même temps à me défendre
si on frappe sur la joue gauche de pas
tendre la droite mais c'est vrai que on
est humain est arrivé à un moment quand
vous voyez qu'elle pût deux solutions
vous arrivé à un point où commençait à
penser comme ça parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution et je voudrais signaler
quand même moi je pense et je suis
d'accord avec la peine de mort mais pour
une catégorie de personnes quand même si
on n'a pas tout le monde dedans c'est le
15 mai 2007
votre vie bascule celle de et nice
également leur va pas revenir sur les
faits parce que c'est c'est compliqué
voilà c'est maintenant passé mais depuis
2007 fait donc 13 ans et nice est-ce qui
est ce qu'il peut vivre normalement
aujourd'hui
ou est-ce que votre vie a été excellent
doit de famille a été brisée depuis ce
15 août 2007
ah oui ça ils ont été brisées s'assurer
que professionnellement socialement
physiquement je veux dire se soigne mes
parents et moi même on a vraiment
vécu l'enfer après après ça parce que
c'est vraiment le vivre pour comprendre
ces c'est impossible de s'en sortir
c'est impossible on peut on arrive à
tenir debout parce qu'on est obligés
qu'on a quand même on vit encore on a un
enfant à élever derrière et on peut pas
se permettre de baisser les bras
mais dire au fond de moi si j'ai pas
souffert si j'ai extrêmement souffert et
à l'heure actuelle gens souffrent encore
vous dis ma santé s'est dégradée mon
père est devenu cardiaque il en ressort
au coeur moi j'ai des maladies enfin
jésus des maladies après ça ma mère
c'est pareil socialement on était
restaurateur on était propriétaire d'une
maison
aujourd'hui je vis dans un hlm après ça
j'étais au rsa voilà tout a basculé
alors qu'on a un rien demandé surtout ce
qui ce qui vous dérange esquive on va
déranger les téléspectateurs ce soir
c'est le profil de l'agresseur francis
evrard multirécidiviste est là quand on
a entendu cette histoire on l'a tous
entendu cette histoire on était tous
révoltés on va pas se mentir on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'il fout dehors
qu'est-ce qu'il fout dehors voilà c'est
ça et c'est ce qu'on s'est tous deux
montés tous veillent donc aujourd'hui
quand quand vous dites
avant je faisais pas de mal à une mouche
et aujourd'hui oui pour ce genre
d'individus je suis pour la peine de
mort je suis persuadé qu'il ya des
téléspectateurs qui se disent quand on
voit ce qu'a vécu mustapha quand on voit
ce qu'a vécu et nice
on aime on ne voit que c'est un
multirécidiviste on peut l'écouter mais
hollande on voit excusez moi vous
découpez me surnommait mondialisme quand
vous voyez que même au procès des
experts psychiatriques qui sont quand
même des savants c'est des gens reconnus
qui disent que cette personne là à l'e3
p est ce qu'ils appellent les 3 pc
pédophiles prêts nets prédateurs ou
enfin si c'est quelqu'un qui peut pas
guérir c'est même pas la peine je veux
dire depuis l'âge de 19 ans est
personnel et comme ça sa 4e assises
sa dernière peine il a pris 27 ans ou 17
ans et leur sortie malgré qu'il a été
jugé encore en prison pour possession
d'imagés pédopornographiques
donc ces remises de peine n'aurait même
pas dû avoir lieu mais on l'a relâché au
17 ans alors que sept personnages depuis
19 ans
enlève des enfants ces questions des
enfants viole des enfants à l'heure
actuelle nous on en a compté que 45
mais à ses dires il y en a 100 parce
qu'il disait en même temps qu'eux il y
avait des enfants qui donnait des
bonbons de l'argent y en avait qui avait
honte ne pas le dire à leurs parents
voilà c est quand vous avez ça au fond
de vous vous arrivez à un moment où vous
êtes obligé de penser comme ça on touche
à votre cher je veux dire c'est normal
ma monfils est le seul que j'ai si
quelqu'un me fait du mal et c'est
automatique que je réagisse et même même
aujourd'hui même s'il a 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans et c'est ma chère même moi j'ai pas
mis une seule cible dans ma vie jamais
j'ai pas aussi un ton envers lui et
comment que la route
il arrive et ce que nice arrive à vivre
normalement aujourd'hui enfin est ce qu
il voit là il est il est quand même allé
très très bien à faire un grand que
vanille ameuté 3 il est très bien grâce
à dieu je vous dis d'ailleurs il est là
aussi j'ai un ange sur l'épaule j'ai un
ange sur l'épaule parce que il ya eu des
circonstances qui ont fait quand vous
dites qu'on l'a retrouvé quelques heures
après ça allait quand même de 14h30
jusqu'à une heure du matin dans un box
feu à cinq ans faut le vivre exactement
pour le vivre est bon c'est quand même
un miracle c'est un miracle je vous dis
jir maintenant alors quand on entend on
va y va on va on va revenir sur
l'histoire bien sûr dénis c est donc
cette affaire mais quand vous entendez
le témoignage de mustapha je m'adressais
à un nom voilà comment on pouvait dire
non à mustapha comment pouvez vous
expliquer votre nom alors je vais
demander à raquel garrido qui est
avocate en plus vous pouvez qu'est ce
que vous pouvez dire au père de perdre
et nice ce soir ça on souhaitait et inis
qui a été donc violi et ont levé par un
multirécidiviste
mais je pense qu'on ne peut avoir que
énormément d'empathie vis-à-vis de vous
de votre enfant moi je suis mère de
trois filles et quand j'entends aux
nouvelles les histoires de viols de
violences conjugales
deux jeunes filles assassinées
défenestré enfin j'aimerais pas être à
votre place et personne personne
n'aimerait être toutefois tour mais je
trouve que quelque part c'est pas
tellement juste de vous mettre dans la
position avoue devoir trouver la règle
commune qui doit régir ce genre de
situation parce que vous êtes
personnellement affectés et quelque part
ce que vous dois la société c'est de
prendre en charge sa par exemple moi ce
que ce qui me choque je découvre par
exemple que il ya une forme de
déclassement social qui est ça qui
accompagnent votre souffrance
ben moi je trouve que ça c'est pas
normal je trouve que la société leur est
dû est solidaire par rapport à ça je
trouve que c'est pas normal de laisser
une famille comme la vôtre s'isoler
peut-être que vous êtes entouré banque
en famille vous voit qu'elle est je
trouve que quand même on aurait pu rater
l'us raquette sous peine arrêté de me
faire une réponse de femmes politiques
basse et de non bâti on reste parce que
là là là dit non mais y qualifier ce
n'est pas vous voulez l'essayer c'est
pas disqualifié monde qualifie peur à
quel moratti et c'est mon empathie n'est
pas feinte will et l'empathie la
l'empathie on en a tous de l'empathie
bien sûr bien c'est ta femme est pourri
nice mais là on a envie que ça bouge on
a envie que ça se reproduise plus a vécu
iny c'est ce qu'a vécu la famille bennis
donc aujourd'hui quand vous dites oui
aujourd'hui quand vous dites non
qu'est-ce qui régit votre nom malaisie
je ne vais pas répéter des choses qui
par ailleurs ont été résumés dans le
tableau que vous avez présenté tout à
l'heure mais par exemple on cesse et il
n'y a pas d'étude qui qui conclut à
l'efficacité écrits de la lutte contre
dans la lutte contre la criminalité de
prenez les états unis où madame va nous
parlait tout à l'heure des états unis
qui est un cas d'école
c'est une société extrêmement violente
où il ya énormément d'assassinât ont
pourtant il ya là il ya la peine de mort
cette idée selon laquelle il y aurait
une sorte d'épée de damoclès et quand le
criminel jeu va passer à la qui se dit
en cour la main il passe à craquer là là
c'est pas ça que je vous dis tu voulais
que ça s'arrête mais pas du tout mes
raquettes ou laisser un multirécidiviste
qui est dehors et comment comment voulez
qu'ils réagissent le papa de mustapha
karim hajji qui est sorti du lot avec
qui il me l'a raconté après je reviens
vers vous rappelle eric naulleau non
mais moi j'ai j'ai assisté au premier
débat sur la peine de mort qui ont
abouti à l'abolition est un des grands
arguments de robert badinter s'étaient
en effet que ce n'était absolument pas
dissuasif y avait quelqu'un qui avait
commis un meurtre qui avait lui-même
assisté à une exécution donc non
seulement il connaissait la peine
capitale
il avait assisté à une exécution donc ce
n'est pas dissuasif
après je dois dire que c'est très
délicat de s'exprimer devant monsieur
cocla coeur parce que on est invité à
peser ces paroles encore plus que kadhaf
vers une néanmoins à l'époque j'avais 20
ans quand la peine de mort a été abolie
et aujourd'hui ma position n'a pas
changé
je dis non parce que je me fonde sur
deux arguments philosophiques
je suis opposé philosophiquement à ce
que des hommes et des femmes se
réunissent pour décider qu'un autre être
humain va être coupée en deux je pense
que personne ne peut décider sa triple
certains dont nous devons penser
autrement mais moi c'est philosophique
ensuite
j'observe que la peine de mort est le
châtiment que s'infligent les criminels
eux mêmes vous avez fait référence à à
ces deux hommes qui ont été tués de sang
froid dans une cave de saint-ouen ils
ont été tués par des truands eux ils
appliquent la peine de mort est ce que
nous devons appliquer les valeurs et les
comportements de ces criminels je le
pense là c'est ma deuxième opposition
philosophie si bien que pour moi le
débat n'est pas la peine de mort mais et
la perpétuité
c'est ça le véritable métier réputé réel
travers lé voilà la haye les théories
ghz on peut estimer que trente ans c'est
une forme de perpétuité
mais elle n'est pas appliquée ou vous
pas suffisamment pour moi c'est
d'ailleurs je trouve c'est une punition
si elle était vraiment à pic et qu'il a
pourrait peut-être un peu plus
dissuasive le type c qui va finir sa vie
en prison